hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Veronica six dos we're gonna watch a
trailer for a little movie that I saved
for my baby cuz I thought you'd be
interested in I have no idea what it's
about
I hear it's a fantasy flick but it's
called big eyes and it's directed by Tim
Burton and it's yeah and I hear it it's
like supposedly pretty good I thought
because it's a Tim Burton movie and you
tend to like his movies do you mmm-hmm
do you know who Tim Burton okay good
this is what it's come to him
you were the only vision someone can
tell my secret to every single one of
them every bigger me no one will ever
know but you
maybe we were there
what's your name why are you ladies
sauce paintings nice those pictures of
the papers and he says posted pictures
of the paintings tonight doesn't know
what kind of person is your husband that
kind of personal
you've heard of my baby maybe I could
sign it myself
that sounds a bit confusing doesn't it
he means me if you tell anyone this in
vertical axis I've had surprise second
from a distant team look like a painting
class adjustment which there
you know what the truth is
the artists interesting I think it looks
fantastic it's cool to see Tim Burton
doing a realistic film again yeah I
never I don't think I've ever seen that
Tim Burton film that was just I was real
semi-normal I love the plot of it it's
so different this like husband and wife
who and he's just totally biggest dick
of all time he's just such a douchebag
that big of an [ __ ] and he seems
believable at it you know I love Amy
Adams she's so beautiful and such a
talented actress and I enjoy her past
work I like tying pieces to the set
design looks really good the production
design all of it looks really good the
performance is solid it's such an
interesting story about self-respect you
know and about honoring yourself
this woman has put herself in this
position to light a light about herself
you know like deny who she is and stuff
like that's that sucks
it said being married to the person
who's just like um no I'm gonna tell
people I did it that's horrible - he's a
douche douche McGee she was auditioning
glorious bastards and he's a douche
again actors from Breaking Bad yeah
she's great she's cool yeah thanks
thanks for giving me that you know
outcome I needed that desperately you
know I like this actor Terence Stamp
he's the guy who almost got stabbed with
the fork at the end I like that guy
I we didn't really see much of him in
the trailer but I what he's always a
delight for me to watch a delight an
absolute delight yes you're sorta sexy
how do you do it I swear you always seem
like you're irritating sexy what do you
think I'm here Willy
you come out of out of nowhere
that compliment like that baby yeah see
we're nothing like that I don't think
really annoying we're nothing like that
couple into that movie we're good we're
good
baby stop for the [ __ ] camera would
you Jesus hmm sorry baby
I'll give you a kiss but you deserve if
you guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects we call
ourselves the real rejects but we don't
really reject much and Veronica has a
channel too I am a channel guys where
there's stuff on it about Veronica
there's lots of stuff about me
viral monster shout me out a viral
monster there's no way in hell I'm gonna
support these evil deeds of yours that
you desire you sick son of a [ __ ] you
know what he wants to do what he wants
to go viral with a video that I sent him
of my penis it was a mistake I made a
long time ago you're on down vital
monster you are going down that's the
video he wants to go viral you're a
monster
pie nation hey every one of you guys are
awesome I would love a shout-out and uh
yeah keep being awesome pie nation we
are a nation of pies if you think about
it like the pie chart it's like 80% of
people in America or white 20% are black
are you saying that there are such
things as Mexican Americans when you
punched in the face right on dude
you mean punched in the pie no sense I
tried making his name work and it didn't
work
Omar Marquez can you tell Sally hey baby
this is about Sally I think she's the
most gorgeous girl in the world
oh you [ __ ] keep your [ __ ] it
Christian Bale Terminator Salvation
bringing that [ __ ] back oh I get a
shout-out from her please nope we're
skipping you because she's not here
right now
180 jobs give me a [ __ ] shoutout
[ __ ]
people keep calling me [ __ ] okay
okay that's your that's your comforting
words baby it's okay to be a [ __ ] it's
okay you're my [ __ ] you're my little
[ __ ]
don't you forget it you call me a [ __ ]
in bed mm-hmm we'll discuss those things
later
118 chubbs its Chava no its chubs nope
oh it's chubba I had material prepared
in my mind for chubbs not Sheva don't
even know what that is but just do chubs
is for chubs for short no it's not gonna
make sense down and 1:18 like how is
chubba gonna relate to my 118 on the
east joke it just doesn't make sense how
this is gonna
thanks a lot Chava mother [ __ ]